einen wunderschönen guten Abend zu einer
Sondersendung hierbei Bild live bei mir
zu Gast ist der Mann der schon in
wenigen Tagen Bundeskanzler werden wird
und der dann vorallem meine Frage
beantworten muss wie besiegt Olaf Scholz
Corona schönen guten Abend Herr Scholz
sie kommen gerade von einer Besprechung
telefonischen Besprechung mit den
Ministerpräsidenten und der Kanzlerin
die deutschen interessiert vor allem
eine Frage wird jetzt wieder alles dicht
gemacht
wir haben ganz konkret über die
Maßnahmen gesprochen die dazu beitragen
können dass wir genau für diese
Situation und diese Entscheidung nicht
so einfach gestellt werden also ganz
konkret ganz unmittelbar geht es darum
wie können wir jetzt bis in den Ende
Dezember bist Weihnachten möglichst
viele Bürger Bürger mit einer Impfung
Versehen Auffrischungsimpfung für
diejenigen die schon zwei Impfung haben
das Boostern und wie geht es mit
denjenigen die sich noch nicht bisher
haben impfen lassen wenn wir da bis zu
30 Millionen Impfung schaffen dann kann
das dazu beitragen dass wir die jetzige
Welle brechen aber
z.b.
darüber gesprochen
es geht aktuell vor allem diese Maßnahme
mit dem
[Musik]
Präsidenten
Zeugung weil das dazu beiträgt dass wir
den Schutz erhöhen und natürlich ist das
auch zumutbar für diejenigen die sich
entschieden haben sich nicht impfen zu
lassen und wir werden Ausnahme machen
für den Beamten täglichen Bedarf Service
klar aber es muss natürlich für alle
anderen diese Sicherheit herrschen damit
das infektions Geschehen unter Kontrolle
bleibt wir müssen dafür Sorge tragen
dass die Kontakte der ungeimpften sehr
beschränkt werden auch darüber ist
diskutiert worden wir werden festlegen
jetzt in den nächsten wenigen Stunden
morgen bis übermorgen spätestens wie das
konkret sein soll oder nicht möglich
damit das möglichst einheitlich ist wir
werden da wo die Inzidenzen sehr hoch
sind wo das Ansteckung Geschehen sehr
sehr intensiv ist dafür Sorge tragen
müssen das dann auch Clubs und
Diskotheken nicht einfach aufbleiben
können in den Schulen gibt es jetzt
schon viele Tests und zwei Massen
eingesetzt werden müssen und wir deshalb
wird er getestet deshalb gibt es die
Masken und wir müssen da Sorge tragen
dass wir auch einrichtungsbezogene eine
Impfpflicht durchsetzen für die dortigen
Beschäftigten der Deutsche Bundestag ist
da auf dem Weg ich selber hat gesagt was
wir auch noch brauchen ist dass wir ein
Gesetzgebungsverfahren auf den Weg
bringen wo jeder Abgeordnete nach seinem
Gewissen abstimmen über eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht lassen
allgemeine
ausgesprochen und haben gesagt sie
würden auch im Bundestag dafür stimmen
heißt das allgemeine Impfpflicht für
alle kommt
ich finde das unmittelbar jetzt
erforderlich ist in dem
Gesetzgebungsverfahren
vorbereitet wird das heißt
ich habe alle geimpft haben weil wir
erleben doch jetzt jeden Tag was
passiert wir haben eine hohe Impfquote
aber sie ist nicht hoch genug und weil
sich so viele Bürgern und Bürgern noch
nicht geimpft haben haben wir jetzt das
Geschehen und haben wir jetzt die
Probleme mit der Pandemie und das ist
doch was wir jetzt ändern was bedeutet
dann dieser Satz den sie dort gesagt
haben wann kommt dann die Impfpflicht
für alle bedeutet das wenn sich nicht
genügend Menschen geimpft haben bis zu
einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt wollen sie in
Bundestag und wollen darüber abstimmen
lassen dass mein Vorschlag ist dass wir
ja nicht als Regierung agieren weil das
eine Gewissensfrage ist sondern dass
hier aus dem Kreis der Abgeordneten
heraus einen Antrag im Deutschen
Bundestag eingebracht wird oder
verschiedene Anträge die genau das
regeln wann wieder eingebracht ich gehe
davon aus dass es noch dieses Jahr los
geht denn meine Idee mein Vorschlag ist
ja dass der Zeitpunkt bis zu dem dann
jeder und jede sich habt impfen lassen
auch nicht allzu fern liegt also mein
Vorschlag Anfang Februar oder Anfang
März und es heißt es muss auch jetzt
bald losgehen dann ab wenn es eine
Impfpflicht für alle gebe die dann durch
den Bundestag käme bedeutet dass all
diejenigen die nicht sich nicht impfen
lassen die müssen Strafe zahlen solche
Regeln werden damit verbunden sein dass
man das auch Umsetzung gibt es in
Deutschland ja immer zu über muss ich
zahlen Regeln dann hat Regeln zu
beachten das ist alles noch gar nicht
konkret festgelegt und kann im Verfahren
gemacht werden wir sollten jetzt auch
ernsthaft bleiben es geht um das Prinzip
zu ernst es geht um das Prinzip und wir
alle haben jetzt mit ganz dramatischen
schwierigen Situation z.b. den
Krankenhäusern zu kämpfen die Männer und
Frauen die Frauen und Männer die in den
Intensivstationen der Krankenhäuser
arbeiten ob das nun das Pflegepersonal
ist die Ärztin und Ärzte die sind damit
konfrontiert dass weil sich zu viele
nicht haben impfen lassen jetzt dort so
viele in den Intensivstation sind und
deshalb ist es doch auch eine jetzt
unter diesen Umständen wo wir genug
Impfstoff haben moralisch vertretbare
Position zu sagen um uns alle zu
schützen ist das jetzt mal ein Fall wo
auch möglichst alle sich impfen lassen
ich möchte ihn einmal zeigen was sie zum
Thema Impfpflicht noch ja vor weniger
als drei Monaten gesagt habe
ich finde es wäre falsch wenn jetzt eine
Debatte Weg beginnt über im Pflichten
und ähnliches
das nicht mal drei Monate her wer soll
ihn als künftiger Kanzler vertrauen wenn
Sie das erste Versprechen jetzt schon
brechen sie sollten wir vertrauen denn
es geht ja darum dass man mit einer sehr
ernsthaften Lage sehr ernsthaft umgeht
und die Lage ist auch gut beschrieben
wir haben haben immer darauf gesetzt
dass möglichst viele sich überzeugen
lassen und wenn wir jetzt an der
Impfquote hätten die bei 80% über die
ganze Bevölkerung lege oder weiter
drüber was noch besser wäre und was ja
auch anderswo erreicht wird in der Welt
dann würde das eine andere Situation
sein und hätte ich meine Meinung zu
diesem Thema nicht geändert aber es gab
er diesen kausalen Zusammenhang nicht
bei ihnen nicht bei einsparen nicht bei
vielen anderen Politiker nicht die haben
sich im Bundestag gestellt und haben
gesagt wir garantieren wir versprechen
es gibt keine Impfpflicht aber nie davon
die Rede wenn wir Ziel XY dich erreichen
das ist doch für all diejenigen die
Verschwörungstheoretiker den Tellerrand
gucken geschrieben habe ja die Politiker
werden uns irgendwann zwingen das ist
doch da sind doch alle
Verschwörungstheorien die gerade wahr
werden dabei die Verschwörungstheorien
werden ja auch eine ganz bittere andere
Weise gerade war es ist doch so dass
tatsächlich die Tatsache dass es so
viele sind die sich nicht haben impfen
lassen die Ursache dafür ist dass wir
heute als ganzes Land eine große
Problemlage haben und das will ich noch
mal ergänzen es ist ja so dass viele
Bürger würde sich haben impfen lassen
und die müssen jetzt Einschränkungen
akzeptieren die daraus etwas damit zu
tun haben
wird das führt doch zu einer weiteren
Spaltung der Gesellschaft diejenigen
können angelogen ich bin nicht mit ihrem
Zynismus
weil wir sie nicht haben müssen wir dazu
beitragen dass dass sich ändert deshalb
auch der General deshalb der Krisenstab
deshalb impfen und Boostern als große
herausfordert riesige riesige
Gemeinschafts Anstrengung von Bund
Ländern
Landkreisen Städten und Gemeinden in
Deutschland also mach das Militär bald
suche sozusagen sucht die impf und
willigen oder was man sie mit dem
General der organisiert jetzt erstmal
die Angebote denn auch in ihrer Zeitung
und überall wird berichtet über die
Frage klappt das mit dem Impfstoff sind
die im Zentrum groß genug gibt es
genügend Leute die das Organisieren wie
ist die Logistik das muss ja organisiert
werden und das wollen wir auch die beste
Weise hinkriegen lass es bleiben sie im
heute in der internen Sitzung gesagt
weil der Schutz der Impfung über die
Zeit deutlich nachlässt wird der
Impfstatus perspektivisch nach 6 Monaten
seine Anerkennung als vollständiger
Impfschutz verliert heißt das also man
braucht ein Dauer im Pfarrbüro alle 6
Monate erneut das wissen wir noch nicht
aber wir wissen auf alle Fälle dass die
jetzige dass der vollständige Impfschutz
mit zwei Impfung anders als gehofft im
früher z.b.
nicht die Wirkung hat dass er für so
lange Zeit reicht und deshalb ist es
jetzt ja so wichtig dass viele Bürgern
und Bürger sich anstellen was sie machen
und sich ärgern darüber dass es nicht
gut genug klappt aber wie kalt der mit
dem du dann an wenn sie sagen
möglicherweise alle 6 Monate und jetzt
sind wir Schlangen wo 3 Stunden 4
Stunden die Menschen warten müssen auf
den Impfstoff das kommt bei den Bürgern
und Bürgern so an dass sie sich darüber
ärgern dass es nicht alles flutscht und
deshalb ist es ja richtig zu sagen wir
können jetzt nicht einfach so
weitermachen wir brauchen einen neuen
Anfang und noch mal der Krisenstab der
ist jetzt ja die Antwort dadrauf wie
kriegen wir das hin das wird nicht von
einem Tag auf den anderen gehen das muss
ja eine enge Zusammenarbeit geben da
wird nicht von oben nach unten befohlen
da wird zusammengearbeitet aber es muss
ja ein Rad in das andere greift und das
wollen wir hinkriegen Krisenstab und
vielen SPD kritisiert immer wieder Jens
Spahn den jetzigen Gesundheitsminister
gleichzeitig gibt es aber ein Impfstoff
Beauftragten der von ihm damals
eingesetzt wurde was macht der
eigentlich der macht dr sehr gut oder
besser nicht im Stau wer wurde von der
Bundesregierung eingesetzt und der
Impfstoff ist ja auch überall
organisiert es geht ja darum dass wir
die Reserven organisieren dass wir es
möglich machen den nächsten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten immer im Stoff Kapazitäten
zu haben dass wir z.b. Produktion
hochfahren können und dass wir in einer
Situation wie der wo wir vor zwei Jahren
waren jederzeit aus dem Stand heraus
diese Produktion etablieren können und
nicht sagen müssen leider sind alle
diese Produktionsstätten nach Asien oder
anderswo anders hatte jetzt nicht
funktioniert in den letzten Monaten ganz
offensichtlich mit dem sonst gäbe es
jetzt ja nicht diese langen Schlangen
Hamburger Elbphilharmonie vier Stunden
die Menschen im Zusammenhang
zu den Bürgern und es ist auch sehr viel
organisiert werden und genau das ist die
Logistik Aufgabe von der wir hier stehen
dass wir es schaffen dass die vielen 10
Millionen Dosen die wir jetzt brauchen
dann auch zur Fügung stehen wenn sie
gebraucht werden und das ist genau der
Grund warum wir jetzt diesen Krisenstab
etabliert hat in dieser Endrunde gesagt
sie sollten will ich nicht bestätigen
was sind irgendeiner internen Runde
gesagt worden ist auch wenn Sie das
gerne immer so sage ich sagen was meine
Meinung ist aber wir kennen ja die
Details aus diesen internen runden wie
Sie wissen von daher m kann ich zitieren
was Markus Söder dort gesagt hat er hat
gesagt sie mit ihren Krisenstab sollten
wir lieber jetzt ein Gesundheitsminister
benennen warum ist Karl Lauterbach immer
noch nicht Gesundheitsminister die SPD
wird Anfang nächster Woche sagen wer die
Ministerin und Minister sein werden die
in das künftige Kabinett einziehen
vielleicht darf ich darauf hinweisen
dass es beim letzten Mal zu diesem
Zeitpunkt gar keine Entscheidung über
die Bildung einer Regierung und
überhaupt keine neue Benennung von
mindesten Ministern geben konnte weil
die Verhandlung zwischen CDU CSU und
Grüne und FDP gescheitert waren sicher
nicht und es neu begonnen wissen Sie
schon wer Gesundheitsministerin
Gesundheitsministerin wird sie sollen
noch überrascht werden wir werden am
Montag
hat die notwendigen Entscheidung von mir
und von der SPD auch mitbekommen hat
kann aber noch eine Chance wir machen
eine gesamt Vorstellung und wir machen
überhaupt nichts was darauf hinausläuft
dass sie jetzt nach Popschlager Prinzip
sich irgendwas zurecht legen können wir
haben vorhin schon immer noch da uns
gesprochen mögliche regionale Locke und
ich will ihn auch einmal zeigen was sie
zu lockdowns gesagt habe
wir werden keinen neuen Lockdown haben
und wir können die Kinder die Schüler
Mitschüler auch wieder im
Präsenzunterricht in den Schuhen haben
steht dieses Versprechen kein lokta und
mehr und Schülerinnen und Schüler im
Präsenzunterricht darum geht es doch
jetzt deshalb sind die Maßnahmen die
jetzt ergriffen worden sind in das mit
dem masti mit den Massen das ist das
intensive testen das ist was einige
Länder entschieden haben dass sie den
Schulen und die Ferien etwas früher
beginnen lassen alles Maßnahmen um exakt
das zu vermeiden und gleichzeitig
organisieren wir jetzt ja dass das
Problem dass wir in Deutschland bekommen
wenn nicht genügend geimpft und gepostet
sind für uns kleiner wird mit jedem Tag
indem mehr Bürgern und Bürger Booster
geht es ich will das noch mal
wiederholen um Millionen das ist etwas
was wir in extrem kurzer Zeit jetzt
schaffen müssen und das mitten unter
ganze Geld bringen dann hat er nicht
geschafft in den letzten Monaten siwonia
Vizekanzler aufgibt dann dieser
Regierung wir haben doch beim Impfen
völlig versagt wir haben jetzt ja ein
Weg beschrieben wie das gehen soll und
ich habe mich sehr sehr gefreut dass der
General mir zugesagt hat für diese
schwierige Aufgabe der hat viel
Erfahrung in Deutschland mit genau
solchen Krisen und ist ein sehr
erfahrener Mann der auch mit vielen
anderen gut zusammenarbeiten kann worauf
ist Jan kommt sie gelten ja als Fan von
Helmut Schmidt verfügen sie auch über
diese Härte dieses sozialdemokratischen
Bundeskanzlers ehemaligen ich finde
Helmut Schmidt ist ein großartiger
Politiker gewesen und ich bewundere ihn
für das was er gemacht hat und wer
Einführungs Amt ausübt sollte auch immer
die Klarheit haben die dazu gehört und
die Bereitschaft Entscheidung zu treffen
ist der Kampf gegen Coruna ist das
schwieriger als der Kampf gegen die
Sturmflut 1 und wie können Sie als
Kanzler was für ein Vergleich die
Sturmflut war eine große große
Katastrophe die uns im Zimmer auch
gelehrt hat dass man aus diesen
Katastrophen etwas lernen das dass es
notwendig ist auf solchen Katastrophen
Konsequenzen zu ziehen z.b. nicht auf
die nächste zu warten sondern die Deiche
hört zu bauen darum geht's ja auch wenn
wir jetzt so eine große Aufgabe
anpacken wie den menschengemachten
Klimawandel aufzuhalten als großes
industrielles wirtschaftliches
modernisierungs Projekt denn wenn wir
das machen dann schützen wir uns ja auch
vor solchen Katastrophen wie wir sie
jetzt in diesem Jahr erlebt haben mit
den Hochwassersituation in einigen
Teilen Deutschlands und für mich ist es
so dass wir jetzt natürlich eine ganz
ganz groß Herausforderung haben und da
müssen wir alle zusammenhalten da soll
nicht der eine auf den anderen zeigen
und aus meiner Sicht kommt es auch ganz
entschieden darauf an dass wir mal
Wunden haben wie die heute wo ohne das
vorher der Beschluss schon ausgehandelt
ist und alles mögliche stattfindet und
jeden Tag irgendjemand einen moin auf
Gerichten Vorschlag Markt beredet wird
was kann man miteinander tun das ist
jetzt die Grundlage für die Entscheidung
die diese Woche dann zusammengeführt
werden und genau so muss es gehen und
übrigens nicht nur diese Woche letzte
Frage zu dem Gerona Thema weil dass sich
viele viele Eltern fragen viele
Geschäfte Inhaber fragen sich dass sie
alles gesagt es wird kein Lockdown geben
und sie wollen Präsenzunterricht können
Sie das Versprechen bleiben die Schulen
offen bleiben die Geschäfte offen wir
haben jetzt die Regelungen getroffen die
notwendig sind um in eine solche große
Situation wo alles wieder so wird wie im
letzten Winter nicht hinein zu kommen
und das muss jetzt jeden Tag unsere
Anstrengung wert sein denn das wäre ja
eine ganz bittere Konsequenz weil wir es
nicht schaffen dass sich genügend
Bürgern und Bürger Boostern lassen
wollen dass ich bin neu impfen lassen
wollen weil wir es nicht schaffen das
Impfen zu organisieren müssen wir dann
Maßnahmen ergreifen die unser soziales
Leben oder unseres wirtschaftliches
Leben beeinträchtigen und das genau will
ich vermeiden kein Bundesland mit ihm
gesetzgeberisch ist ja jetzt eine andere
Rechtsgrundlage geschaffen worden und
die ist auch die Basis für das was jetzt
gemacht wird und noch mal bitte nicht
immer nur Sprüche klopfen in der Politik
sondern handeln und das Handeln des
jetzt anliegt ist die Tatsache ist das
Impfen und dass wir das Organisieren und
das muss erste Priorität haben handeln
das fordern viel Bürger auch beim Thema
Inflation Herr Scholz großes großes
Thema 1 Rekord Inflation die wir gerade
erleben und ich möchte ihn einmal zeigen
was Ulla schon eine 80 jährige Rentnerin
zu dem Thema gesagt hat sie hat gesagt
als wir sie interviewt haben dieses Jahr
werde ich zum ersten Mal auf den
Weihnachtsbaum verzichten müssen ich
kann ihn mir einfach nicht mehr leisten
auch wenn die Enkel traurig sein werden
ist es bitter alles wird teurer und
teurer bei uns im Wohnblock wird schon
in zwei Wochen vor der Rentenauszahlung
hin und her geborgt damit man sich
wenigstens etwas zu beißen kaufen kann
was werden sie gegen die Inflation tun
tun ist mal müssen wir etwas dafür tun
dass nicht der Bürger noch Bürger die
ein ganzes Leben lang fleißig gearbeitet
haben am Ende mit der Rente so knapsen
müssen wir haben schon in der jetzt zu
Ende gehenden Legislaturperiode Hubertus
Heil und da sehr engagiert gearbeitet
die Grundrente auf den Weg gebracht um
da eine Aufbesserung zu ermöglichen und
viele kriegen jetzt hier Stück für Stück
die Bescheide die diese Verbesserung in
der Rente dann auch ermöglichen und
gleichzeitig muss es darum gehen dass
wir natürlich nicht hinnehmen können
dass es auf Dauer eine hohe Preis
steigen Inflation gibt wie sie das eben
beschrieben haben die Fachleute in der
Welt sagen gegenwärtig noch darf ich mit
aller Vorsicht dass es sich nicht
dauerhaft aus wächst aber das müssen wir
natürlich ganz ganz sorgfältig
beobachten und dann die notwendigen
Schritte zu ergreifen falls die sich
geirrt haben für den einmal zeigen was
Professor Schnabel Direktoriums Mitglied
der EZB dazu sagt sie hat nämlich gesagt
die Inflation sei zu Trick das bedeutet
aber dass wir ganz genau hingucken
müssen dass wir wachsam sein müssen um
frühzeitig zu erkennen bist eben doch
Entwicklung gibt die darauf hindeuten
wenn es einem mittelfristig eine zu hohe
Inflation geben könnte aber zuvor in
diesem Lied Zitat sagt sieht Inflation
sei mittelfristig ein ich zu niedrig
sehen Sie das auch so ich weiß nicht aus
welchem Zusammenhang dieses Zitat aus
einem Interview von gestern zu einem
Interview von gestern sagen Sie mir
jetzt aber ich weiß dass die EZB die es
in der Regel im Hinblick auf einen
Inflationsziel von unter ein 2% gesagt
hat und nicht im Hinblick auf die
Dimension diese nein meine Aussage ist
in dieser Frage ganz klar eine hohe
Inflation wie wir sie heute haben
sollten wir nicht anstreben da bin ich
völlig festgelegt und deshalb ist es ja
so wichtig dass wir genau hinschauen
haben die Experten Experten aus aller
Welt recht die sagen das hat das zu tun
mit der Corona Krise mit der
Rohstoffknappheit mit den and steigenden
Preisen die da rauskommen mit den vielen
Konjunkturprogramm die nicht nur wir in
Deutschland in Euro Personen viele
Regierungen aller Welt auf dem Weg
gebracht um um aus dieser Krise
wirtschaftlich wieder rauszukommen und
das wird sich wieder normalisieren wenn
das nicht der Fall ist müssen wir was
tun
in der nächsten Woche großer Tag für Sie
sie werden vereidigt wer sitzt da von
ihrer Familie auf der Tribüne haben sich
da schon entschieden wer es eingeladen
könnte ich ihm sagen und
er ist nicht der öffentliche
Bekanntmachung sind die eingeladen die
kommen wollen
wenn Sie sich jetzt vorstellen erster
Arbeitstag dort im Kanzleramt wissen Sie
schon wie es losgehen wird um wie viel
uhr wacht Kanzler Scholz auf wann ist er
dann im Kanzleramt wie läuft sowas ab es
machen sich schon sehr viele Gedanken
über meinen Terminkalender nach der Wahl
ich nicht so weil ich ja noch dabei bin
alles dafür zu tun dass das eine
ordentliche Regierungsbildung wird und
gleichzeitig jetzt Jahr herausgefordert
bin lange bevor ich im Amt bin mit den
Aufgaben die sich mit der Corona
Pandemie verbinden und wie wir das
hinkriegen die Gesundheit der Bürger
Bürger zu schützen das kostet meine Zeit
und darin sind meine Gedanken
immer gut gelungen ich ziehe zwar
persönlich zu den Leuten die gerne mal
ausschlafen würden aber in meinem Leben
ist es anders gelaufen wenn sie die
ganze Wohnung nutzen im Kanzleramt ich
habe mir darüber keine Gedanken gemacht
aber ich wohne in Potsdam und bleibe da
auch wohl das wird ihre erste
entscheidung als Kanzler sein
das habe ich noch nicht für mich
festgelegt und es wird auch nicht so
martialisch sein und es geht darum dass
man loslegt mit der Arbeit an die Arbeit
ist die Parole wo gibt es da ein Thema
neben Corona dass ihnen besonders am
Herzen liegt wo sie sagen da will ich
jetzt anpacken das will ich jetzt
schaffen es gibt eine ganze Reihe Themen
die mir am Herzen liegen und die Krone
Pandemie ist die eine große Aufgabe vor
der ich und wir alle jetzt stehen und wo
wir alles geben müssen damit das so gut
wie möglich in Deutschland bewältigt
werden kann aber es gibt auch viele
Dinge die ich mir ganz dringend
vorgenommen habe für die kommende
Wahlperiode ich habe immer gesprochen
über einen Mindestlohn der auf 12 €
steigen soll das wird schnell kommen ich
habe immer gesprochen über stabile
Renten ein stabiles Rentenniveau auch
das wird kommen ich habe gesprochen
darüber dass wir was tun müssen für die
Kinder mit einer neu gefassten
Unterstützung für Sie einen neuen
Kindergeld an der Grundsicherung für
Kinder und darüber gesprochen dass wir
auch das Bürgergeld neu etablieren für
diejenigen die
brauche ich habe darüber gesprochen dass
wir mehr Wohnung brauchen und natürlich
immer auch über die Frage wie schaffen
wir gute Arbeitsplätze beste Frage
Scholz wie werden wir Weihnachten feiern
in Corona Zeiten wird es da Kontakt
Beschränkung geben wie viele Leute
werden wir versammeln können und dann
bauen kann man da schon sagen es wird
jetzt auf alle Fälle für ungeimpfte
Kontakt Beschränkung geben das glaube
ich ist ein Konsens der sich weit
verbreitet habe ich habe das ja auch
sehr klar gesagt dass das meine Meinung
ist und stehe auch dazu und
dann müssen wir natürlich hoffen dass
wir mit dem Maßnahmen die wir jetzt
ergreifen eine Situation erreichen wo
das was uns gegenwärtig besorgt sich
dann allmählich wieder die Lage sich
wieder verbessert weil wir es geschafft
haben voranzukommen mit impfen und
Booster herzlichen Dank
Bundeskanzler
Spezial live Gespräch hier bei Bild nach
einem besonders ereignisreichen Tag